we're going to begin with a historic
speech from ukraine's president directly
to the united states congress today
president zielinski is asking the u.s to
enforce a no-fly zone over his country
to stop russia's devastating airstrikes
against his people this video was taken
this morning in the capital of kiev
which in the capital city of kiev which
is enduring frequent attacks from the
air the air campaign has been even more
destructive elsewhere but the u.s has
grave concerns it says about taking a
step that could escalate this conflict
chris lipsay is in odessa that's on
ukraine's southern coast it's a city
that is supposedly in the crosshairs of
russian forces chris what do you know
good morning tony a strict curfew is
underway in keeve until tomorrow morning
this after renewed shelling struck the
capitol capital and hammered cities
across the country
keeve
once again in the crosshairs at least
four people were killed inside their
apartments plunging the capital into
fear and now into lockdown until
tomorrow morning
even more dire is the nearby city of
harkee ukraine says russian shelling has
killed at least 500 residents and
crushed more than 600 buildings since
the start of the war
schools nurseries hospitals and homes
leaving no peace even for the dead
at this funeral air raid sirens
interrupt the tears these war weary
mourners hardly flinch
the latest violence making it even more
stunning that the prime ministers from
poland the czech republic and slovenia
are risking their lives to meet
ukraine's president in the capital a
bold show of support for the
independence of ukraine
but the siege of cities like miracle cut
off from food water and power only gets
darker ukraine reporting that russian
forces have taken a hospital and its
patients hostage and are using it to
attack the city while drones from russia
this video released by its defense
ministry captures strikes on ukrainian
armored vehicles from above all of it
fueling europe's biggest humanitarian
crisis since world war ii in only three
weeks of fighting more than three
million refugees like this little boy
i'm children and i am scared of war
i don't like war
but despite setbacks ukraine is defying
the odds and bogging down the enemy this
video set to music claims to show
wrecked russian tanks and overrun troop
positions
in the coastal city of nikolayev ukraine
is repelling fierce nightly onslaughts
and turning russia's weapons against
them
ukrainians aren't just beating russians
on the battlefield they are capturing
their armored vehicles check this out it
was clearly taken by force and over here
on the side there used to be a z the
classic sign of loyalty to putin and his
war they've painted it over with
ukrainian flag
and then swiftly put to the front lines
in the information war the local
governor vitaly kim credits local
residents with slowing the russians on
their rampage across ukraine's black sea
coast and beyond and how long will you
have to fight the enemy
to the victory
or to the death it's two ways only
and we just want to take a moment to
honor our colleagues at fox news who
came under fire outside keeve in their
vehicle on monday
sadly cameraman pierre zakshevsky and
local ukrainian producer 24 year old
alexandre kufjanova were killed and
correspondent benjamin hall remains
seriously injured fifty-five-year-old
zxzewski was a seasoned veteran in
conflict zones and widely respected by
his peers kuchinova's bravery and
professionalism shows the tremendous
contribution local producers make to
four news crews such as ours cbs news
relies heavily on such dedicated
individuals we could not be more
grateful for the risks they take and the
sacrifices they make gail
so well said chris it's a painful
reminder that people who are bringing
you this these stories are also risking
their lives
thank you chris livesay in ukraine